um
out
check with us
we can
sorry
um okay
people okay so that's going to be
so jaclyn's so we do have you done
before so we do that
each position so we have one two three
there's no one out in the hall now so
i'm hoping it'll stay that way
um huh
see i just jinxed myself this is why we
don't say change
that's the lesson of this press
conference so far just don't say
anything
never speak
gwen stefani had it right all those
years ago
what
please
uh
um
okay
um
right now it's just it's just
spring training is underway
it uh matter
uh
sometimes
i think
on what
there'll be at least 12 people there
not anymore i was growing up
the killer bees era
no oh interesting
everybody
all right
don't mess this up
let me train for this
we got a line now
um
right here
good morning everyone and it is a good
morning we are so
excited that today the equality act will
come to the floor
uh we have passed it in the house before
the equality act hr5
to end discrimination against the lgbtq
community
this time that will be not only passed
in the house
but on a path to a signing at the white
house
we're very excited about that later
we'll be gathered i think right here
right to talk about that more
specifically but i want to salute
thompson david cecilini for his
leadership on this legislation
and senator merkley and just point out
that when we
announced that legislation
john lewis stood with us
as a leader as a leader in that
passing equality act again we're
waiting as we all are to hear from the
senate parliamentarian
as to what will happen with the
minimum wage piece of the legislation
i don't know what other considerations
she has but i feel
that we have a very very strong argument
and we have a very big need in our
country
to pass the minimum wage we've been
working on this this
fight for 15 for a number of years now
and
it's long overdue and it will be phased
in
and we would hope that it could be part
of this reconciliation deal
uh but uh could be any moment if you
hear
someone haven't found me if you hear
before i do let me know okay
uh and then that will be
as you know is part of our american
rescue plan
that we are putting forth it's it's
about putting
vaccinations in the arm money in the
pocket
children in the schools workers and
their jobs
and it is it's what this country needs
and i salute the president
uh for recognizing those needs and
courageously going forth and the
american people
it like over 75 american people support
the legislation
overwhelmingly democrats republicans and
independents
support the legislation so hopefully by
the end of the day tomorrow
it will be passed and then and prepared
for this
to send over to the senate by monday
morning for them to act upon it
and then if they change it they'll take
it back and pass it and then send it
out to the white house we're very
excited about that
and it is receiving such very widespread
support
from economists and their need for
something substantial is very recognized
as well as the timing at a time when
interest rates are low so the need is
great
the opportunity is there and the
precision of this legislation to
directly
address the needs of the american people
the lives of the american people
and the livelihood earlier this week we
sadly observed
the over 500 people 500 000 people
who died from the coronavirus i was so
pleased
that we had a big turnout of democrats
and republicans house
and senate on the steps of the capitol
for a moment of silence and
music no speeches music uh
to share our sympathy with the families
of those who have lost their loved ones
any questions madam speaker yes sir
again the other uh the other week prior
to the senate uh verdict
uh on the impeachment trial um you're
asked
whether there might be something else
democrats might think about a punishment
if there was not a conviction or a
censure and you said you might have
something to say about that i wonder if
there's anything you guys are looking at
uh maybe even two hundred thousand plus
pensions that trump gets as a next
president
or is this a kind of close chapter in
your book no i i think that uh
what i was thinking of is that we have
to get
what we need he's going what we need is
the truth
and that's what we want to find out the
truth about
what is happening in our country to
enable something like this
to be acceptable to the republican party
secondly the obviously the separate from
him uh the need for us
uh to secure the capitol in a way
that gives people confidence that they
can visit
their children can come and see this
temple
of democracy but um
so many things are happening outside of
the congress
in regard to your question that uh
right now our focus is on finding out
the truth and i'm
disappointed in what i heard
of the minority leader yesterday
mcconnell say on the floor of the senate
it was really quite stunning because in
my commerce
brief conversation with him on this
subject i had the impression
that he wanted to have a a
january 6 similar to 9 11
commission but what he said on the floor
was really a departure from that
it seemed when he spoke that he was
taking a page
out of the book of senator johnson
it was really disappointing he said you
could do something narrow that looks at
the capital
or we could do potentially do something
broader to analyze this
full scope of political violence problem
in this country no we have a domestic
terrorism challenge in this country
that's what the the uh director
of the fbi testified to the end of
september
domestic violence taking more
lives than international violence
in this country and the biggest number
since
oklahoma city uh the
biggest buckets under that category of
domestic violence
were white supremacy anti-semitism
another list of xenophobia homophobia
etc
i reference i refer you to his statement
so for this leader of the senate to make
light
of this and and is is
well it's don johnson was his first name
john
what is it ron
ron johnson seems to be taking the lead
on what the scope would be of how we
look
at protecting our country from domestic
terrorism madam speaker on that topic
can i follow up on that topic yes the
minority leader and others have also
said they would want to see this
commission be a
50 50 bipartisan split why have you not
wanted to go down that road and
are you concerned about who republicans
would appoint
to be on a commission like that no the
uh
i uh you know i was the author of the
legislation then
for the 9 11 commission uh it was passed
in the
senate and the committee and the
intelligence committee
i lost on the floor the ball was picked
up by tim romer
and he with the uh enthusiastic support
of the
families of 9 11 was able to pass the
bill but it was resisted
at first by a republican colleague not
in the committee i wanted a committee
but
not on the floor of a half they were in
the majority
the um and uh
that was a different time a different
commission the most recent commission of
scope
has been uh the the uh one i take great
pride in the
uh centennial of women's suffrage uh
that was a committee where each of us
had two
and the president had two so was six
to four that isn't unusual to give the
president
um and if we don't talk about democrats
and republicans
these could be independent they could
all be one i
i hesitated to put in there uh that
there should be a difference only of one
because
maybe more independence would be named
we don't know because there's a criteria
for who it is
so it is uh that's not the point though
that's easily negotiated
the point is the scope if you don't know
your why
if you don't have your purpose as to
what the purpose of this
is then the rest of it is
is a not the important part of the
conversation
though are you concerned though if the
commission
were to have a lack of equal liberty
that the public would have confidence
then number one and then received your
point about the scope
then republicans would look into saying
uh political protest violence last
summer from the left and then that would
be
their uh method of kind of saying okay
we're gonna
we're not gonna be focused just on what
happened at the capitol we want to look
into what happened well that's exactly
what my uh
we had an event on january 6
which i'm sure the world has not
forgotten
at that time there was a dissent
on the capitol instigated by the
president of the united states
for an insurrection on the capital
and on our democracy to overturn or to
prevent the electoral college
votes to be counted and the president of
the united states to be ascertained
after there was an assault on the
capital
and those of us into his credit senator
mcconnell leader mcconnell was part of
it
he insisted on coming back to the
capitol
to resume the proceedings not doing it
in offside or any of that
he was very much a part of coming back
to the capitol
even after an assault on the capitol
they still
insisted on objecting to another state
to take us
into four o'clock in the morning and
then
overwhelmingly voting against the count
and and so we're saying okay something
happened here
there's a it's about domestic terrorism
we want to solve this and now i want
will do anything to have it be
bipartisan
so as your point is that it would be
well received
by the american people
it's the ron johnson school
of january 6
but can you talk to us about why this
equality act
is needed and secondly about the
republicans calling it an attack on
religious liberty and religious freedom
and
open up to lawsuits
the uh thank you for the question
i love talking about the equality act
the
it is needed because there is
discrimination against people in the
lgbt community
to give you a little background on that
uh we had for a long time
a series four things that we were going
to do
one was we were going to uh
pass hate crimes legislation which we
did
and so proud of that matthew shepard's
parents helped us
pass that legislation secondly we were
going to do
um the repeal of don't ask don't tell
which under president obama's leadership
and
with his courage in the rest we were
able to do that
the next thing we were going to do was
end up to end discrimination in the
workplace
but then it was like well why just the
workplace
why not in every aspect of the economy
and of our society
so we went to the equality act so that
it was more comprehensive than just
in the workplace and that's where we are
now and our fourth
was not our doing it was the courts was
marriage equality and the courts took
care of that
for us so the piece that was remaining
of the four that we
set out to do a number of years ago is
the uh
now the equality act it's it's
manifestation earlier it was ender
but we broadened it and it is necessary
because of this i wish it weren't
it breaks my heart that it is necessary
but the fact is
and in fact we have
a sad event here even this morning
demonstrating
the need for us to have respect not even
just respect
but take pride take pride in our lgbtq
community thank you very much really
yes it doesn't seem that you've made
changes to the legislation or the police
reform legislation since you
passed it in 2019 2019 2020.
you still need 60 votes in the senate so
how do you see the path to this becoming
law
if republicans won't sign on well we are
passing the legislation here
which was is a very balance and thank
you for your question about
the george floyd justice and policing
act
which we will have on the floor next
week
um the uh no we uh and congresswoman
vass
to her credit i worked in a very
very diligent and fair way to put
something together
that was respectful of those in the um
in blue uh
who do their work so honorably and and
to whom we are in debt but also to
recognize
that not everyone does that and so this
is what that legislation is about
what the senate will do with what the
senate will do but we will send over the
bill
that has the balance that we have in it
when we sent it over before the senate
said well we're for all these things
let's study them and it was that well
we're either going to do something and
we're not going to do something but
we're not
hundreds of thousands well millions of
people marched in the street
all over the world not just for one day
but over and over again to say
make the change that is necessary and
this legislation when we had the hearing
for it
in the house the family came
george flake's family came and they said
now speaker will you name the bill
for george floyd and i said
i will only name the bill for george
floyd if you
think it is worthy of his name
now let's go into the process they did
and we are honored uh to qualify his
name
uh coven really on covent relief um
you know let's say the parliamentarian
does allow the minimum wage what's your
strategy to get it done isn't it going
to be an uphill climb with manchester
united others against it
is there some what's the path forward on
minimum wage no you're going to have to
go ask that question on the senate side
uh but we are very very pleased with the
a case that has been made
and uh we will ha we will pass
we will pass a minimum wage bill
we must pass a minimum wage bill
again when we had the majority in 2007
one of the first bills that we passed it
was part of our 6406
and the first 100 hours we passed
the minimum wage bill 7.25
it had not been passed in 11 years
now it's even longer
after we passed it in the house it went
over to the senate
and uh toward the about the 22nd
of january a senator from
west virginia senator byrd put out a
press statement
supporting the passage of the minimum
wage
and how important it was to the people
of west virginia
i call that to your attention because
he might be an unlikely advocate but he
was out there urging that
when we passed it in the senate we went
out and had a big
i would say a rally i guess on the lawn
and i spoke for the house democrats and
senator kennedy spoke to the senate
democrats
and he said you know what we have to do
now
we have to pass the minimum wage
recognizing that
already that was not enough
for a family to live on so here it is
what that was over
seven in january signed by president
bush
signed by president bush george w bush
uh and and um what are we
14 years later we still haven't raised
minimum wage
thank you all very much i'll see you
some of you
thank you